funny the quality of what's being
transmitted I sort of was getting at
this before when I said you need a
high-speed internet connection ok now
the comparison is what you're going to
have is something something similar in
ideal situations right so if everyone
has a great connection the network's not
too busy right you've got good hardware
and what kind of thing the the
difference in st. audio quality because
I can't really compare video quality
because telephones don't have video
quality right the quality in the audio
will be quite similar right talking on
the phone versus a teleconference ok but
if they're there isn't an ideal
situation in terms of communication
systems right for instance suppose you
wanted a communications network it goes
down or your ISP is just really busy but
you go on in a peak period or something
like that ok because the Internet has
what we call and this is um this is
actually something with probably most of
you so far in my market haven't seen
anyone who named it that really players
it's a hard thing it's a packet
switching connection right packet
switching which means that you know when
you're sending data ok you don't send it
as one big continuous scree stream ok
you chop it up into packets ok and then
you sort of unfair e them along bit by
bit ok now can you see why there's a
problem if you're trying to talk to
someone and listen to their voice in a
continuous way why packet switching is
going to lead to some problems ok if you
don't have an ideal connection you know
you've got a whole bunch of packets of
audio data that gets sent along right
and then they get held up for some
reason maybe the server they went
through got clogged up or there were
some errors and so they need to get
resent ok that's different to you got a
web page and it takes a while to load no
big deal right bits of it load of
different times and that's okay you
still get the same experience but
because audio is synchronous in nature
and we're sending it in an asynchronous
way ok does that make sense Lou say that
again audio is synchronous in nature
it's
time-dependent if you don't get the
audio data on time you don't get it
right you just hear you know gaps in the
in the sound okay it just cuts out okay
and if you ever seen like a Google+
Hangout or something like that even
after they've been recorded you still
get this problem okay if you're sending
secrets data in an asynchronous fashion
you're not going to get the same kind of
quality in transmission right now let's
keep going I've been told you so far out
telephones so let's think a bit about to
face to face communication tell me some
similarities do me a compare surrounded
yeah good it's all that body language
stuff we were talking about before I'll
bet in common okay so you know you still
get the visual element of the
communication okay that's good but the
big difference is where you've got to be
physically located at the same place
right so that's even more difficult to
arrange than telephones now with regards
to this business that causes some
significant problems okay can somebody
tell me somewhere we're going to be in a
physically same place so why is
face-to-face communication going to be a
problem number one and number two what
actual problems is it going to create
for us
okay said yes exactly right there not
just geographically like a little bit
apart right like the next room over or
something like that this is about as far
as we can get like opposite ends of okay
so all right sometimes right suppose we
want no teleconferencing system you're
gonna need to communicate face-to-face
still right so how would you do it what
kinds of things what kind of Hoops
you're gonna have to jump through
because you can't just say get on him
you got just say I'm gonna have a
beating let's let's go to right what
kinds of things are you going to have to
think about well number one how you
gonna get yes I ok good right so even
assuming I can get on a plane and go and
see you right you might be asleep when I
get there ok so it's not just that if
you're going to see people face-to-face
and you've got an international
organization this isn't just gonna if we
want to talk for two hours or something
like that ok this is not going to take
two hours this is going to take like
three days ok how does it take to fly to
the US it's like it's a long time right
for city to city of the u.s. how many
hours does anyone do it's a bit honey 18
or 19 that's crazy isn't it that's
three-quarters of a day on the plane
when you arrive the dates different ok
not to mention time zones in that kind
of thing and how the date I don't know
I'm be confused but ok so it's a big
venture right so not only is a better
there's a time cost ok just actually
getting there is expensive right and
then staying there is expensive ok so
not just as their cotton time there's
big costing money ok I'm already going I
think you're getting at the problems
okay all right now there's a few other
issues that we haven't mentioned but
it's done in touch on here right we have
a name for this kind of concern it came
on a project manager right it's a kind
of feasibility right this is economic
feasibility
but they're not the only kinds of
feasibility involved in fact for a
question like this right even though
probably when you read this you didn't
think our this is project management
okay it looks like a communication
system question and it is ok but what we
learn on a project manager will really
help tell me what are the other kinds of
feasibility what's another one okay
technical okay we've sort of touched on
this already but let's go on to it a
little more detail right technical
feasibility means you're gonna have to
have all of this equipment right which
is what the next question is about okay
and that all of these equipment that has
its own cost right so this is a really
good issue cuz it goes both ways right
it's a it's a good compare and contrast
right so you might if you go
teleconference II right you might save
the money of travel but what do you
spend your spare money on the internet
you spend money on the hardware there's
a big initial cost right so maybe you
skip ongoing costs of you know
accommodation and travel right but you
have to lay down this big you know make
thousands of dollars to get all of the
hardware that you need and have it based
at all of your different offices okay
all right let's technical feasibility
give me some other ones schedule now not
just can you um and some of you did
mention this which I was really glad
about not just do you have to think
about okay it takes a long time to do
this kind of thing right but also I
think time zones gets into this right
you can't just have a meeting right if
you're going to go face-to-face you're
gonna not just um you can't just call it
up and they know hey hey can we talk
right now right not even hey tomorrow
can we do this if you're going to fly
how long it amiss do you think this
thing's gonna be scheduled one at least
a week and I'd expect longer like you
probably have them you know maybe say
once a month or something like that and
you got them later you've got the dates
right because like a week if you think
about it can you imagine you're working
in you know this organization and you've
got a family and all that kind of thing
and your boss says hey I need you to go
fly to London in six days
in a week right I need you to be there
for three days yeah you'll be gone
further it is really like I think a week
is actually the bottom for what's
reasonable to expect of your employees
to say okay we'll get you guys to go
overseas and travel for a few days okay
so not just the time investment but the
time that needs to be sort of planned
out okay there's one more kind of
feasibility pop yeah so you know um in
terms of operational feasibility this is
about how does the system work and does
it achieve our purposes okay so you can
think of this in terms like productivity
so again thinking from the vantage point
of teleconferencing right what are the
prior to meet advantages I've already
started to address some of them they're
all interrelated how productive or you
have you spent 18 hours on please answer
not very even if you're flying business
class that kind of thing you're a jet
lag and all that kind of thing there's a
big part of any cost involved with
having to travel somewhere else and do
me okay so that's a tick for
productivity rate increase not to me but
to the conference's systems they are
getting easier to use but most people
still don't know how to use them
effectively okay so there's still a
productivity cost at the mini you can
you need training okay you need people
to set up the system and all that has it
set up an operational feasibility class
okay